so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host Carl smore and today we're talking
about the Lites raging Against the
Machines and as with all videos on this
channel this one is based on a script
submitted To Us by our team of writers
this one in particular being Larry
holsworth if you enjoy what you read
give them a follow of the Social Links
below but let's get to
it the first Industrial Revolution which
occurred in Europe and America from
roughly the mid 18 Century to the mid
19th centuries was a period of rapid and
sometimes quite dramatic change it
sometimes defined as a period which saw
the shift from a largely agrarian
society with manufactured goods produced
by Craftsman to an industrialized
Society where machines did it it's
instead so machines took over roles that
were previously filled by skilled men
and women and in doing so eliminated
long-standing occupations basically
eradicating them from history as just
one example the spinning of yarn and
thread along the domain of women in the
household became mechanized yarn and
thread became less expensive and more
readily available for consumers and at
the same time households in small towns
and Rural locals lost a long held source
of income as the Industrial Revolution
ran on manufacturers which is still an
awesome word I'm glad I get to say out
loud emerg powered by wind water and
eventually Steam for decades water
provided the most reliable power source
and it drove a continually expanding
number of machines Grist Mills Sawmills
looms Spinners and other Innovations of
Industry some were also powered by human
feet operating in little pedals like I'm
doing right now to make sure my camera
works and the treadmill led to the
employment of children many wait what oh
sucks anyway many of these labor
intensive jobs in the factories became
the occupation of children and child
labor evolved into a social issue as
well as an industrial one cities
expanded as workers flocked to the urban
environment seeking employment for
themselves and the other members of
their households few cities were able to
easily absorb the increases in
population and tenaments and slums
became a curse on many a in living and
working conditions were just a part of
the price of progress crime became a
problem In Crowd of cities ethnic
neighborhoods emerged bringing with them
the signs of intolerance and Prejudice
that continue to this day while the
owners of factories grew fortunes from
their profits the workers found
themselves largely unable to purchase
the fruits of their own labor the result
was resistance to progress to Innovation
and to change each new invention found
those who opposed it each new system
found those Desiring to return to the
old the one certainty throughout the
period was change a certainty which some
greatly
feared beginning in the mid 18th century
and largely driven by Great Britain and
that nation's Colonial Empire the
industrial revolution saw machines
replace human hands in the creation of
many guts although the techniques of
mass production using prefabricated
Parts did not emerge until the later in
the period raw material such as flax and
Cotton Were converted into usable
Fabrics to the use of Machinery forger
shaped iron using hammers powered by
water and later steam water power drove
meat packing plants moving animal
carcasses to workers bearing knives axes
and saws again made by machines and
other machines pounded the bones of
these animals into powder for fertilizer
candle making up to then the perview of
Housewives or skilled Craftsmen became a
machine driven industry so did the
rendering of fats to make lad Tallow and
soap many Industries became regionalized
based on the availability of the raw
materials to produce the things they
wanted to and to drive the Machinery
required to create them with water being
the primary source of power for many
years tows located along navigable
waterways became Industries WS provided
the means to receive raw materials Drive
the machines that process them and ship
the finished goods to customers Allin
one Service as it were although machines
assumed the burdens of manufacturing
they still needed workers to operate and
maintain them workers were also needed
to package the products store them in
warehouses or prepare them for shipping
what had been small relatively isolated
towns became cities as workers abandon
their rural homes and relocator to these
manufacturing
centers
machines to knit spunar and thread into
cloth first emerged in the mid 16th
century in Britain they were known as
stocking machines since the manufacturer
of knitted stockings was a major reason
for their existence their operators were
known as stocking gers which is a cute
and wholesome word we should bring back
early machines mimic the Motions of hand
knitting and the operators required
similar skills by the mid 18th century
improvements to the mechanical motions
of the machine as well as its operation
had eliminated much of the human skill
required the machines were also
expensive meaning individual stocking
gers could not compete with the
wealthier manufacturers who purchased
multiple stocking frames and established
factories for the manufacturer of
knitted Fabrics including Silk and Lace
and we all know that stockings are
better when they're made of silk and all
a by the mid 18th century Nottingham
England was a center for the stocking
frame Richard AR established a mill in
cromford where the stocking frames were
operated by water power use of water
power continued for decades in
Nottingham the advancers in the machines
produce less expensive Woolen and cotton
stockings and other knit materials as
well as more luxurious Silk and Lace
again Silk Stockings like they'll change
your
life the advancers also displaced
workers who had labored at individual
machines then rendered non-competitive
with newer mechanization stockinger
rebelled with the preferred method of
demonstrating displeasure being the
Smashing of the expensive stocking
frames themselves by the second half of
the 18th century The Rage Against the
Machines was extended to the new
mechanized spinning machines which
created Yarns and threads eliminating
the jobs of yet more workers in
Lancashire a major spinning Center by
1760 displaced workers join their
stocking reverend in smashing the
machines they perceived the source of
their employment Wes the protests and
destruction of the expensive Machinery
grew to the point the textile
manufacturers sought protection from
both the crown and from parliament in
1788 A Member of Parliament from the
textile manufacturing districts
introduced the protection of stocking
frames Etc Act of 1788 Daniel kooch MP
representing Nottingham argued the
willful destruction of stocking frames
and other textile industry Machinery
should be punishable by the infliction
of the death penalty yes they literally
wanted to to kill people for hitting
machines with hammers because the
machines represented profit and you
don't interfere with a rich person's
profit even a little bit Parliament
debated and ultimately agreed to that
laws to protect the industry but
declined to go as far as to make the
destruction of a stocking machine
punishable by death instead the Act made
attacks which led to the destruction of
stocking frames and the Machinery like
it a crime which led to force
deportation for a period of 7 to 14
years for each individual offense can
only imagine there were judges who got
very creative with that and just listed
like you know each swing of the Hammer
as a separate offense yet attacks and
destruction of stocking frames and other
machines continued and in 1812
Parliament modified the previous act
citing its ineffectiveness in protecting
the machines of Industry judges were
given the authority to sentence
offenders to Alternative punishments at
their own discretion which did include
the death penalty or lengthy prison
terms so yes they would literally kill
people for destroying machines in
factories because the people who own
those factories were Rich enough to bend
the ear of um the right people in power
and get them to lay down those
punishments sure I'm glad we passed that
today right AR you
guys the increased use of machines LEDs
to the creation of the factory system
which in turn led to less expensive and
more available Goods in many Industries
productivity increased towns grew into
cities cash money in circulation
increased and the quality of living
increased for many many more were left
on the side though and those are the
ones we talking about today jobs in the
new factories were increasingly
dependent on unskilled laborers which
were cheaper for employers to hire and
or replace skilled workers found they
were pretty undesirable in the grand
scheme of things to factories unless
they were willing to work for
considerably less money than they were
used to receiving for their labor the
steadily increasing number of factories
in industrialized areas were erected
with little concern for the comfort and
indeed safety of the workers conditions
were harsh lighting ventilation and
space to move about were inadequate in
most factories hours were long wages
were paid by the day or week rather than
by the hour and in some Industries wages
were determined by the number of goods
completed rather than by the length of
time it required to produce those goods
where in the early days workers in some
Industries Weavers for example enjoyed
some protections by joining together in
crafts and gills the factory workers had
no such organizations unions were
non-existant and protest against
conditions or against the low wages
typically paid in VAR led to dismissal
and in some cases prosecution
blacklisting disruptive employees made
them pretty much unemployable and was
effectively a death sentence if not
financially then quite literally for
some people the new Factory has
established uh there to four unknown
labor pool preferring to hire women and
young children they were viewed as less
likely to complain and were considered
to be more docile they were also paid
less child labor quickly became the norm
in factories in Britain by the late 18th
century larger families led to more
potential earners under the same roof so
people started having more kids so they
could send them to the factories to work
children who had been in an early age
apprenticed out to a Master to learn a
trade with room and borders Rec compend
became unskilled laborers living at home
on a pittance the factories also became
a major source of pollution discharging
their waste into the waters that also
powered their machines later when steam
power was introduced it led to the heavy
consumption of coal which polluted the
air so air and water are gone and the
lands not looking too much better as
well this led to cities becoming known
as Prett unhealthful sites dominated by
crowded housing Smoky air wreaking
waterways and a grumbling discontented
population of people who probably
smelled real bad
Employers in the factories of the
Industrial Revolution did prefer child
labor whenever possible they saw many
advantages to the use of children for
one they were more easily ordered about
and they lacked the ability to resist
through protest or through Force they
were also able to be paid less earning
as little as 20% of what adult male
would be paid for the same task corporal
punishment was common in the factories
and where an adult male could be
expected to physically resist punishment
you know just knock his supervisor the
out for trying that A Child would likely
not and a child who did resist could be
more easily subdued as well or simply
just ordered to go away children also
offered the advantage of a smaller size
a significant asset on the shop floors
crowded with Machinery they could crawl
into spaces inaccessible to adults reach
into the nooks and crannies of Machinery
that was too small for adult hands and
what few laws did apply to labor during
the early days of the Industrial
Revolution favor the employer and not
the workers regardless of age or sex
children work shifts as long as 16 hours
per day age of little importance to
their employer What mattered most was
obedience size and coordination please
don't take that out of context the
attitude of most employers towards their
Workforce including children remember
during the Industrial Revolution was
summed up by an 1832 House of Commons
report by that time the attention to the
plight of child labors in the British
factories have become a social issue a
situation which did not exist in the
late 18th century the report stated in
part and I quote workers are often
abandoned from the moment an accident
occurs their wages are stop no medical
attendance is provided and whatever the
extent of the injury no compensation is
afforded speaking of children being
injured this was pretty common in
factores throughout the century or so
during the Industrial Revolution these
injuries included but were not limited
to crushed hands and feet maimed and
lost limbs the loss of eyes Burns
disfigurement and all too often death
and there's not any details in the
script but I have read about this um
when writing and researching other
articles and scripts and also during my
like um schooling when stories of
children being trapped or crushed by
machines was so common that was like
artwork of it in history books and it's
like okay speaking of which Charles
Dickens was a leading critic of the use
of child labor and he knew what he was
talking about having me a child laborer
himself while his father s in Dead's
prison by the time Dickens wrote his
most famous works the use of children in
the industrial Workforce was a century
old towards the end of the period
recognized as the first Industrial
Revolution the British government
finally took action regarding the use of
child labor and in the early years of
the 19th century it passed a series of
laws known as the factory acts in 1819
it established the first law in Britain
regarding child labor decreeing that
children were limited to a work day of
just 12 hours ain't that
sweet the emerence of factories requires
several factors to be in place to ensure
their success mostly a source of power
wind or water in the early years of
Industrial Revolution later supplanted
by steam engine a means of transporting
finished goods and receiving raw
materials was like likewise required
usually waterways highways that sort of
thing and eventually railroads another
necessity was the labor force Town
surrounding industrial areas grew as
families migrated to them for the towns
and Industrial Revolution imposed
demands for housing which increased
throughout the period the burst of
population growth in these towns and
cities created crises that they were to
put it likely ill equipped to face since
recorded time began and people gathered
in communities poorer areas of
settlements existed the Industrial
Revolution led to a steady increase in
the size of these poor areas most
Factory workers commute to their place
of employment on foot or if they were in
larger cities in tumbrils wagons or
omnibuses they needed to live where they
were it's the Industrial Revolution led
to the expansion of slums and tenaments
in the industrial areas many of which
gained well-earned infamy in British
cities such as Birmingham Nottingham and
Liverpool Hy built multi-unit tenament
housing sprouted most units held entire
families grandparents parents children
and relations by marriage in one or two
rooms which must have made making all of
those babies that they needed to you
know go work in the fact for a pittance
really awkward when you think about it
your entire family is in one or two
rooms how are you making more babies so
the tenaments were often built back to
back with narrow mus Alleyways between
them the alleys hous the common privies
and trash pits where clothes were
laundered and hung to dry and these
tenaments were very often overcrowded
and seldom had running water or even a
well and just in case it wasn't
depressing enough it's noted that most
of the time these buildings would just
house workers from the same Factory as
Cole emerged as the prime source of fuel
for heat and for power in the factor is
the Aira most cities became foul with
its smoke the Waters of nearby streams
became equally foul polluted with the
coal ash the awful of humans and the
effluence of the factories crowded
streets were further clogged with animal
waste the bodies of dead animals and of
course the poop people were throwing out
of their windows in the United States
like during the Industrial Revolution
several cities just allowed pigs to
wander the streets freely taking
advantage of their pension to eat
virtually anything including human
effluence the Industrial Revolution
didn't just change industry and cities
it also changed agriculture the
development of machinery for Farms like
mechanized seed drills and threshing
machines increased the productivity of
farms while reducing the need for Farm
laborers this led to a push from The
Agrarian regions to the urban areas
which offered the pull of jobs most
migrating from the farms to cities were
poorly educated and unskilled the
perfect fodder for the labor force
demanded by these new factories they of
necessity sought the least expensive
housing available in their location
feeding the expansion of poorer areas
into the cities and exacerbating all of
the issues mentioned
previously in the early 19th century the
Napoleonic Wars in Europe at their
heights the New Movement began in Great
Britain many of the worst conditions of
the industrial revolution had yet to
take hold few factories were powered by
Steam and the smog and pollution of the
ensuing decades had not yet marked large
cities to the degree they later would
yet workers in Britain especially in the
textile industry had already seen enough
and they didn't want anymore the British
economy was strained by the effects of
the ongoing W of Napoleon trade embargo
imposed by the United States and
international disputes with Sweden and
Russia food prices where food was
available were high and so were the
prices for fuel clothes and other
finnished Goods the textile industry was
in a downturn due to shortages of raw
materials and across Britain inflation
was high and wages depressed the British
government largely ignored domestic
issues with its intention focus on the
war with Napoleon Britain largely
maintained that war by offering
financial support to potential allies on
the night of March 11th 1811 disgruntled
textile workers gathered in Nottingham
demanding increased pay for their labors
British troops were called in to
disperse the protesters as they did
another group of protesters smashed
weaving machines nearby it was the first
indication to the authorities that the
protest might be well organized and
indeed planned they were with the
textile workers involved meeting in
secret in isolated areas and selecting
the targets of their protests the group
selected textile mills smashing machines
they found there and then vanished into
the night they targeted the machines
which they deemed presented the greatest
threat to skilled labor in the regions
in which they were found over the course
of the several months they targeted
knitting frames in the Midlands in
Liverpool steam powered loons were
destroyed in their protests and these
protests if you've not guessed it by now
were the work of the Lites who for
anyone curious took their name from a
fictional protest who smashed stocking
frames in 1779 in a possibly apole story
named Ned l so Ned Lord Lites and the
Lites were noted as being highly
organized and they struck frequently
enough where the authorities were kind
of tired of what they were doing so the
term Lite has come to refer to someone
who opposes advances in technology and
the changes they on society aik rages
Against the Machines of progress but the
machines though they were the physical
targets of aik protests were not the
real targets of their activity many of
the leaders of the laikes were skilled
laborers who used the machines of the
textile industry instead the laikes
protested against the use of machines to
displace skilled labor and produce
cheaper products with unskilled labor
and though today the term Lite is
largely used as a pejorative if you go
back and like you know look at the
demands they had in their protests and
read their manifestos you'll notice some
St similarities to labor disputes today
for example the Lites wanted to end
child labor they wanted higher wages for
skilled workers better working
conditions in factories and Union
representation for all people working
within them though they were organized
there were different Lite movements each
related to the specific section of the
textile industry in which their members
were employed But ultimately they all
had the same goal better representation
for workers more compensation for the
workers working in factories and you
know not literally feeding children into
machine to feed the profits of
capitalism you can't I can't think of a
more overt symbol like the cost of
progress than they were literally just
pushing children into machines there the
old joke is like the orphan crushing
machine of like oh you know we've we've
we got rid of the orphan crushing
machine people don't know the reference
that it's a it's a it's just an internet
idiom of like oh we finally managed to
shut down the orphan crushing machine
it's like but why does the orphan
crushing machine exist
the British government responsible L
Movement by strengthening the stocking
frames act allowing judges to impose the
death penalties to violators they also
dispatched troops to quell the protest
leading to Armed clashes where some
protesters were killed in 1813 over
12,000 British troops were occupied in
suppressing the Lise a larger number of
troops than those fighting Napoleon's
Army in the peninsula War the acts of
the L drew the attention of Lord Byron
who became a local and Ardent supporter
of their goals which to his mind had
been distorted by the government and the
British press byn addressed the House of
Lords in 1812 describing his impressions
of the workers in the British factory
system he spoke in denunciation of the
change as to the stocking fraes act
telling the house and I quote been to
some of the most oppressed provinces of
turkey but never under the most despotic
of infidel governments did I behold such
squalid wretchedness as I have since my
return in the very heart of a Christian
country in 1813 over 60 men were
arrested and tried in York under the
terms of the revised stocking frames act
30 men were eventually acquitted those
found guilty were subject to harsh
punishments at least 17 were executed as
many as a dozen were deported as convict
labor probably to Australia the harsh
response of the British government to
the Lites as well as to what was largely
described in the British press as an
Insurrection that benefited Napoleon led
to them being condemned in the public
mind for decades and even to this day
the term Lite is a pejorative to many
describing someone fearful of technology
and the changes it brings in more recent
scholarship though they have been viewed
somewhat differently you know especially
considering what they were ultimately
fighting for was stuff that we're still
arguing for
today eventually social reformers and
Common Sense caught up with the
technological changes wrought by the
Industrial Revolution or at least some
of them later governments came to
realize that societal problems were both
reflected by and created through the use
of children to manufacture the products
consumers purchased workers organized
and demanded better wage better working
conditions access to Medical Care all of
which as we mentioned were changes
demanded by the Lites during their brief
time on the stage a second industrial
revolution occurred at the beginning of
the 19th century and continued
throughout the first half of the 20th
century organized labor and management
addressed the problems of the first
Industrial Revolution through various
means some successful others not so much
company towns labor riots union busting
scab labor minimum wage laws child labor
laws mandatory School attendance laws
and countless other efforts to prevent
the problems boring the first Industrial
Revolution have all come about some
solved problems while creating new ills
which were as of yet unsolved the
industrialized world still deals with
overcrowding his cities industrial ways
polluting waterways over tax Waste Water
treatment systems unhealthy air quality
and other societal issues which first
appear during the shift from an agrarian
to an industrial society today it's
robots and AI that threaten to replace
skilled workers with machines the use of
fossil fuels is threatened if that's the
word by alternative sources of renewable
energy including wind and water power
somewhat ironically given everything
we've talked about today just as the
workers in various Industries once felt
threatened by the emerence of machines
so they are threatened again bring it
back to the L IES they do not react with
blind Rage Against the Machines which
arrived to change the future they
protested the means by which some the
few exploited those machines and what
they produced at the expense of those
who were less Fortuner they demanded a
fair wage for a fair day's work
producing a quality product which
reflected their skills and benefited the
consumer to some such a desire was and
remain simply unattainable quite
unfortunately there is an old saw which
states that a modern day Lite had
invented a machine machine which would
destroy all technology and that was
never really the goal of the laikes
instead they wanted all to see the
benefits from technology with the
benefits derived equal to the effort put
in only time will tell if such a goal is
attainable but one thing is certain
advances in technology are not going to
stop where those advances are attained
by humans or by machines they create is
something that remains to be seen so
hopefully everybody enjoyed this video I
certainly enjoyed presenting it as
noticed at the start this video was
based on original script submitted To Us
by Mr Larry holsworth links the rest
socials alongside my own can be found
below if you like the video leave a like
if you got anything to say about it any
topics you'd like us to cover in the
future do so in the comments below if
you want to see more videos like this
subscribe go to our hi sister Channel
Geographics and top 10s to see um you
know more content you know from our
handsome team and stable of writers you
can see more of my content at fa them
with K Smallwood and Wiki weekends as
well as going through the archives of
top 10 list verse today found out and
countless other websites um for which I
probably wrote at least I think last
count like 3,000 scripts for various
websites online so chances are you've
probably seen some of my work elsewhere
and thank you if you have like you know
I didn't get paid for it for the view
but I did get paid for write it
initially which is always
appreciated